in this video we are going to talk about
variables and also a concept called
camelcase they're not necessarily
related but we're gonna cover them both
variables are any value that you want to
set you initially save the variable like
there also meaning variable that's how
we say it in JavaScript ver Breanna
teacher equals true we just declared a
variable which happens to be a boolean
from the last video this variable is
also in camel case in JavaScript the way
they keep things legible without spaces
is the first word is completely
lowercase every word after that the
first letter is uppercase but there are
no spaces pretty straightforward let's
do a little inspecting on free code
camps page and see if we can find some
variables and their code so this is the
free code camp home screen we are gonna
open up chrome dev tools which you will
find out how to use later on if you
haven't already and let's just go ahead
and look at their JavaScript file we're
gonna look for a variable an example the
variable on their page and there's a
couple already I can see here there x
equals document dot get element by tag
name that's also an example of Dom
manipulation which is something else
we'll talk about in other videos see
what else have we got here that's the
biggest one that I see the first one I
see so even variable 0 there in stuff
it's another Dom manipulation but this
is how you define variables you see
there you say what you want the there to
be called and then you can put pretty
much anything else that will end up
being equal to that name that you can
reference later on